I had a kid with cancer one child every
2 minutes is diagnosed with pediatric
cancer yeah I read about your kid having
leukemia Johnny Christopher yeah yeah
thousand treatments well he went through
1,95 days then he went to remission
which is 3 years came back I found it in
his testicles when he came out of the
shower I was like this doesn't look
normal and then he went through another
2 years of treatment so he was in it for
over 6 years it really puts everything
in perspective cuz they're so innocent
it should be worrying about playing with
their toy not like get chemo for many
hours or do a blood transfusion or do a
spinal tap my son was hooked up to
blindat Tuma map basically a machine 28
days a month he lost all his hair so now
my whole mission in life is for the
betterment of children like I raise
millions of dollars for kids every scent
that I raise 100% goes to these kids if
people want to help they can go to Chris
Angel help.com